えーでは始まります まだちょこちょこ超特急でいきますので
あの えーと とにかくあの内容は難しいかもしれませんだけど
あのそれほど理解しにくいものじゃないんです
我々の固定概念だけ置いといて
あの宗教 この宗教と比較しないで聞いてみると
ただの学校の大学の授業と同じなんです
真言宗から見ればどうでしょうかとかね
阿弥陀宗教から見ればどうでしょうかとか
そういうふうになってくると
固定概念が入っちゃって分からなくなります
それだけのことで ただの普通の大学の授業みたいな程度で聞いてみれば
まあわかるものです では
もう一度 パート1で扱ったテーマに戻ります
生命の絶対的支配者というね
仏教が発見する生命の全般的に支配管理する組織
初めはないと言ったでしょ
因果法則や で ブッダの言葉
チッテーナニーヤティーローコチッテーナパリカッサティチッタセーカダンマッササッベーワサマンナブー
あ すってんかすの忘れちゃった
で この世界は生命が心に導かれる
心によって左右される
心というたった一つの法にすべてが支配されると
だからやっぱり支配者がいたんですよ
心という このあの心にいろいろ単語を使ってますけど
このチッタという単語を使う場合は
知るという機能で使っているんです
だから心の代わりに知るということを入れたってもいいんです
この世界 この生命が知ること
知るによって導かれると
まあそれはちょっと日本語的にはなんかややこしいんだから
まあ心に導かれる 心が読んであれ知れ
これ知れと だから心の奴隷というかね
お釈迦様はそんなことをおっしゃってるんだよというぐらいの知恵でいいんです
また 別な訳もあります
タンハエニーヤティローコタンハエパリカッサティタンハエエーカダンマッササッベーワサマンナブー
この世界は生命が渇愛に導かれる
渇愛によって左右される
渇愛というたった一つの法にすべてが支配される
だから まあ知ることから渇愛が生まれるんですよ
知るだけだったらそれで終わるはずなんですけど
渇愛が生まれるんだから
で 我々はいろんなことをやってるんです
だからなんで渇愛と心に 2つ平気でおっしゃったかというと
なんでおかしいんじゃないかなと思うかもしれませんよ
世界は心によって支配されていると言ったのに
言ったのにも関わらず
今渇愛によって支配されていると
どちらでしょうかと どちらでも正しいんだけど
わざと渇愛を出すのは我々に知ることは消すのはできないんですよ
生命がいる限りは 生命っていうのは知るものだからね
知る機械が生命だから
しかし 渇愛ならなんとかできます
我々足すのは修行して悟るということは
完全に知ることを消えることじゃなくて
知るんですよ 知るんだけど
渇愛を作らない 知るのみを考えると心ですが
知って判断に至るので渇愛になるのです
そういう差があるんです
知るのみを考えて真理を語るならば
心に支配されているということになります
知った瞬間に判断するんだから
自分の都合によって だから渇愛によって支配されると言うんです
はい 早く行かないと間に合わなくなります
やはり絶対的支配者がいる
絶対的支配者が心なのです
すべてを支配する一つの心ではなく
すべての生命は自分の心
知る機能を持っているのです
違うところはそれなんです
たった一考の心で支配しているわけじゃないんです
各々の個人が自分の心を持っていて
そちらに支配されています
そこはこの絶対的 神様か仏様か如来か何とかという信仰型の宗教と違うところはそういうところなんです
一時的に他人に管理されることもあるが
本来は他人に管理できないんです
これよく大事なポイント
個人個人が自分の心を持っています
その心が支配者なんです
司令官なんです 人の他人のことってのは絶対聞かない
管理できん たまに管理されているように見えますけどね
でもこれは本来はできません
これすっごい大事なことなんです
実は自分自身にも自分の心の管理はとても難しいんです
私の心を他人に管理できないだけじゃなくて
私自身にも自分の心の管理できないんです
心は管理者だから 司令官だから
そういう管理しがたい
ありえないことを仏教でやらせているんです
次のポイントは 心は自由か暴走するかという自由か自由でないかという書いてもいいんだけど
自由でそれは成り立たないんですよ
心は誰の命令も誰の管理も受けませんだから
自由でないということは言えないんです
では自由自在かか あるいは暴走しているかということになるんです
互いの利益のために会社や政府などの組織がある
規則に法律に管理されてはいるが
ほとんど肉体の管理で心まで管理することはできません
でしょ 当たり前のことです
我々は互いの利益のために
いろんな社会 会社 組織を作るでしょうし
政府を作るでしょうし
法律を作る それは互いの利益のためなんです
それで管理していますよ
皆様 日本政府と日本法律によってもう厳しく管理されています
しかし 心まで管理することは全く不可能です
命を脅かすことである程度のマインドコントロールできます
脅すと できます 命を脅す
例えば法律を見てください
脅す 脅しです 免許取り上げるわ
あの姉は問題で 50万円罰金払うことになるわ
まあアホな連中作る法律だからね
私から見たらどう見てもアホでもうたまらんだけどね
もう例えばあの振動強度がこれぐらいあってほしいというのも
それなりのもう何か何か調べた結果で
まあこれ決まってる強度で作ったんだからって
地震で倒れないという約束はないし
あるいはもう覚悟した上でね
もう柱の柱ばっかしか買うんじゃなくて
住むところ大きいスペシャル家を買うそうと強度はないんだぞと
だから文句あるのかって
なんで個人がそれ買って悪いんでしょうかと
安い もうすごい広々したマンション買っちゃって
安くて でも作った会社がこれは地震には自信がないんだよと
買うか買わないか あんた決めなさいと
それでも別に悪くないでしょうに
それでも地震というのは毎日あることじゃないんだから
地震が来ると逃げると
そういう準備があったら
それはそれで大丈夫でしょうし
あの姉さんの免許取り上げたんだからって
その人にあの設計能力ないんですかね
あるでしょう 普通よりはあったと思いますよ
だからもう極端なギリギリまで
あのね もうそれもすごい計算でやらなくちゃいけないんだからね
ただ減っただけでもダメでしょうし
私は普通の人よりはかなりの優秀な人だと思いますよ
まあまあ それはどうでもいいんだけど
世の中で強盗するなよっていうのは
この脅しがあるんですよね
それで我々 一般的な法律を守っている人は
この脅しにやられていて
だから罰罰受けたくない
身を守りたい 法律破っちゃうと
もう何も守れなくなりますよということで
法律を犯そうとも思わない
今守っている だから冗談ででも強盗でもしようかなとかね
空き巣に入ろうかなと思わない
で その思考さえも出てこない
その思考 なんで強盗しようか
空き巣に入ろうかなと
まあ思わないことは もうこれ思考管理されてますよ
それは脅しによって管理されています
だから脅しがなくなると何するかわからなくなっちゃうんです
逆もありますね ご褒美を約束することでもできます
こうしたらこうなりますよと
こういうことをあげますよというご褒美か脅しか
それでしか心の管理できません
俗世間では 脅しとご褒美の力がなくなると
心の管理はできなくなる
例えば 金がない人には月々 50 万とかね
100 万給料を払うぞと言っちゃうと
金がないんだからもうさっと飛んじゃうんですよ
そうすると あなたはこうしなさい
こうしなさい これでなければ
これはダメとかね  1 日もう 12時間仕事をすることになるんだぞとかね
時々もうもうもうみんな過労で死んだりもするでしょうに
それにそのご褒美でやられてますよ
人ってのは疲れたら寝たいんだけど
この宅急便やとかね もう疲れるとこなくて
若者はものすごい苦労して仕事していますよ
荷物を持っても走ってるんです
自分がいる建物見ると
もう何回もみんなもう走ってるんですよ
もうもうかわいそうですけど
で それでも徹夜したり仕事をして
まあ大変です なんでそこまで人間の自由がなくなったのかと
その人々も遊びたいでしょうし
もうご飯食べて寝たいです
テレビ見たいでしょうし
そういうのを取り上げる
もう考えたこともない
そんなの あれ ご褒美なんですよ
では 金持ちの坊ちゃんに頼んでください
じゃああんた宅急便で仕事してくれないかと
断るんです 例えば 自分にはもう自分の財産で
もう何のことなく 楽に楽に楽々に生活できる
それでそれでもどこかに会社に行って
50万円の給料のためにものすごい苦労して仕事しなくていけないと思わないんです
だからご褒美の力がなくなると人の管理できない
脅しの力がなくなると人の管理はできないんです
だから人間と犬って何が違いますかね
結局は 他人に管理できないからといっても
心は自由ではありません
この意志 希望 計画通りにも心は動かないのです
個人がいろんな私は怒りたくないとかね
欲張りたくないとかね
賭け事 麻薬 酒に依存したくないとか
気持ちはあるんだけど
そううまくはいかないんです
嘘をつきたくないと皆様思ってるでしょ
思っていただけでうまく実行はできるでしょうに
そううまくいかないんですね
業の法則は破れない なぜならば
業の法則たるそれを破ることできないんです
業によってもう考えたりしなくちゃいけないんです
まあ例えば いつでも嫌な気分でいなくちゃいけない業の人がいれば
その人は何を見ても悲観的に見るんですね
どこへ行っても喧嘩を売っちゃうんですよ
褒めたっても喧嘩 何言うんでしょうかと
人を馬鹿にするんじゃないよと言っちゃうんです
それで本人がずっとあの性格で苦しむ羽目になっちゃうんです
また 心には習性によって癖がついてしまいます
知る世界にはもういつでも癖がつくんですよ
習性によって それは心の法則
また 種の法則もあります
種の法則もあります 人間の心で犬の世界も魚の世界も理解知ることはできません
我々は人間の DNA を持っているんだから
我々知っているのは人間の世界だけのことなんですよ
犬の世界どう見えるのか
犬は人間のことをどう考えているのかとか
それはわかりません では
魚の世界観はどうでしょうかと
わからないんです お互いコミュニケーションできないんです
これは種の法則です 生物学は人間の立場から観察した生き物の世界であって
その生き物から見た世界ではありません
それで皆様は平気で言うでしょう
生物学ってあるんじゃないかと
鳥のことやら昆虫のことやら
何でもかんでもむちゃくちゃ分類して
カテゴリーして 生態はこんなもので
食べ物はこんなもので
こういう環境では生きていられる
こういう環境ではダメとかね
偉そうな それは 人間の立場から見た動物の世界であって
そのその生命の世界から見たものじゃないんです
だから生物学っていうのは明らかに人間だけの主観ですよ
種の法則もだから乗り越えがたいんです
感情があると 心は感情に言われるままに
知ることをするんですね
そこで感情が動物にも入りますよ
犬が怒って興奮しちゃうと
飼い主でも噛んじゃいます
興奮していない時は噛んではいけないと知ってますけどね
そこで私たちもまあ立派な冷静でいるそうと思っても
感情が割り込ん割り込んじゃうと何するかとわからないんです
そこでいっぱい心に制限入ってますよ
この遺伝の法則と業の法則と
これから感情 その時制御不可能で心は暴走します
自由じゃないんですよ
人間には人間の視界しか知りませんだから
犬には犬の世界しか知りませんだからね
何でも知りっていうことはありえないんです
これは種の法則で で 感情が割り込んじゃうと
まだ暴走する それから習性が入っちゃうと
また別なもの知ってしまう
はい 次のポイント それで心は自由じゃないということ
終わった 次に心同士の関係
なぜかというと 物質同士は関係ないんです
こんなのわかりやすい
自然法則だからね 物質同士で油と水は一緒にならないとかぐらいはわかりますよ
簡単単純説明も なぜ水に油が溶けないのかとかね
化学者さえもそんなものをできるんだから
随分単純な世界なんです
本当の関係っていうのは
心同士で起こるんです
心は横の関係を築くが
縦の関係はできません
これから皆様初めて聞くことやと思いますけど
心は横の関係を作るんです
縦の関係は作りません
似た者同士という言葉がありますね
似ているなら互いの関係を築くが
似てないならば無関心です
人間で理解してください
我々は似ているならば
お互い仲良くするんですよ
似てないんだったらもう無関心
知る世界 主観の判断の世界が似てないと関係を持たないのです
だから知る世界 似てないと
例えば魚と仲良くすることができないんです
魚が知る世界と我々知る世界
似てないんだから 全くも
だから関係は持てないんです
自分の主観ともう一人の人の主観というのは
まるっきり似ていないならば
仲良くすることはできない
例えば ある人がもう音楽に夢中で
音楽ならもう好きで好きでたまらんと
もう一人が音楽は大嫌いで友達になりませんね
我々は友達を作る時でも
何か似ていないか 似てないか
それだけ探すんですよ
精進について これはなかなか大変なところなんですけど
お釈迦様はもうあんまりたくさん説いてないんで
ある箇所で説いたものをまとめてます
16個ぐらい経典があるんです
1個じゃなくて それで明確にこの横の関係を説明しているんです
心の だから理解したければ
その 16も経典を読まなくちゃいけないんです
例1つだけ出します 精進する
精進する人は精進する人と会う
智慧がある人は智慧のある人と会う
拙者者は拙者者と会う
盗人が盗人と会うという
似た者同士仲良くするんです
例えば あるグループの中で一人のことを知っているならば
グループ全体の気持ちはわかるんです
すごい簡単ですよ だから一部だけパーリ語を書いたんです
ダハトソービックウェッサーサンサンダンディサメンディ
お釈迦様使っている単語というのはダハトという単語なんですよ
ダハトっていうのはこの基本的なところっていうことで
もうダハトによって衆生がサンサンでお互いに融合するんだと
サメンディ同一仲良くするんだと
パーナーティパーティーのパーナーティパーティーっていうのは
折衝する人はパーナーティパーティー折衝する人々と一緒に
あってしまいますと そのようにこの似た者同士でしか我々は関係を持っていないんです
それが横の関係なんです
似てるんだから まあ動物は明らかにね
自分のグループとしか関係を持たない
しかし 動物の中でもかなり頭のいい動物たちはいますよ
犬なのに猫の面倒を見てあげたりとかね
時々テレビで見ますけども
猫が犬の赤ちゃんにミルクをあげたりしたりとかね
知ってますよ 違う生命
でもそこでそれはすごい親切で優しいということなんですね
人間の中でももう自分だけ良ければいいっていうことではないんだから
他の生命にも優しくしたりはする
だから動物に親切 親切にしたり
まあいろいろやったりはする
あのムツゴロウさんでしたっけ？あの人
名前何でしたっけね あの
えっ 畑さん その方はね
もう動物学者で もう動物も自分も別物やと思ってないんですから
もうかなりもうすごい動物たちがもう付き合うことはできているんですね
動物たちもそれはわかるんだから仲良くしてくれる
他の人とは仲良くしません
あっち行けという態度を取るんです
畑さんだったら別にあっち行けということはしないんです
だからこの人間 まあ性格的に似ている
ある日 お釈迦様がサーリプッタ尊者がどこか見たんです
サーリプッタ尊者のところに行って
いっぱいお坊さんたちがいたんですよ
そこで隣にいるお坊さんに言うんですよ
あなたにね サーリプッタ尊者見えます？見えますと
そしたらいっぱいグループがいるでしょう
いますよと みんな知識人だよと
智慧がある連中だよと
だからサーリプッタ尊者に惹かれるんです
頭の良い人々だと それでまたある日
モッガラーナ 目連尊者のところに
目連尊者のところにもいっぱいグループが集めているでしょうね
みんな瞑想の達人たちで
神通を持っているんだと
そういう超能力とかね
それで似たものグループができて
ということで 縄張りの中ということになる
例えば人間に人間のことならなんとか理解できますが
動物の気持ちはわからない
人間より次元の高い生命のことは全然わからない
人間同士でも自分より優れている人のことはわからない
横の関係しかないんだからね
同じ知識レベルの中で似た感情範囲の中で生きているので
成長向上は期待できません
我々は自分に似た範囲の中で
知識範囲の中で仲良くしてますよ
だからみんないっぱい人間関係あるんだぞとかね
仲良くしているんだとか
問題ないと言ったってもどうったことはないんです
似た者同士の関係なんです
似てないとトラブル起こるんです
だから我々は自分の縄張りっていうことはもう乗り越えませんね
だから動物に悪口言ってはいけませんよ
動物は自分で縄張りを作って
そこの中で生きているんだぞとかね
例えば虎だったらきちんと縄張り作るんですよ
おしっこをかけて 猿も縄張りがあって
みんなにありますよ あれは動物だからと
人間も同じなんで 地球は回っているんだけど
みんな自分の縄張りの中で生きているんです
だから縄張りっていうことは動物に限ったものではありません
だから我々は自分より低い生命の動物のことをわからないでしょうし
人間なのに人間の中で優れている人々のことをわからないんです
で 縦の関係って何やと
生命は自分のことしか知らないし
外のことを知ろうとしても
それは自分に関係ある範囲だけです
生命っていうのは自分のことしか知らない
では世界を知ってやるぞと思っても
関係あるものしか知らないんです
関係のないところでストップするんです
したがって 中心的になったりというかね
自己中心 うん 自己中心的になったり
自分が一番可愛く いつでも一番なのです
そういう風になっちゃうんです
生命は ですから 縦の関係なんかは想像もつかない無理なことです
自分が一番可愛いんです
自分の見方で世の中見ているんだから
見える範囲が決まっているんです
自分が偉くて一番なら
縦の関係は成り立たない
どんな生命でも自分が可愛くて一番偉いと思っています
それも生命の一つの決まりです
だから縦の関係は成り立たない
謙虚で素直で 前向きに柔軟性を持つ
アドバイスを快く聞く
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみではなく
慈しみの精神で生きるものでなくてはならないんです
縦の関係を作るためには
こういうものが必要なんですよ
これはなかなかついてないでしょう
この性格は だから横の関係ある限り成長はなし
同じところでぐるぐる回る
成長したければ この性格ぐらいなければ縦の関係は作れません
縦の関係を作っちゃうと成長するんです
例えば 自分よりものすごく頭のいい人と仲良くすると
自分の頭も良くなりますよ
すごい道徳的な人と仲良くすると
自分も道徳的な人間になるんです
でも 自分が謙虚でないとできません
追い出されます 知識的に
精神的に 道徳的に目上の人は自分の低次元に落ちてくれることはありえないんです
だから縦の関係はそんなもんで
上の人は堕落しないんです
分かりやすい例で言えば
人間のことを理解したいんだからといって
自分が人間になりということはありえないでしょう
人間のように 4つの足で歩いたり
ご飯は口で食べたり おしっこは足を上げておしっこをかけたりとか
それで人間の犬の気持ちがわかるんだぞとか
これはやらないでしょう
上の人は堕落してこないんです
代わりに下の人は向上していかないと
だからもうまだまだダメだから
謙虚で素直で アドバイスをよく聞く柔軟性ある人間でなければ
上の縦の関係は成り立たないんです
だから 縦の関係というのは性格的に良い人にのみということになっちゃうんです
犬を飼うと 自分 自分の人生を犬に合わせるのではなく
犬を人間の社会に適応できるようにするんでしょうに
ちょっと脳を入れてください
例えば皆様 犬飼ってるでしょうに
犬を飼ったんだからといって
家は全部犬の世界に入れ替えることないでしょうに
犬が穴掘るのすごく好きなんですよ
だから家で穴を掘れるように作ってあげたりとかはしない
だから人間の生き方に犬を合わせるんですよ
おトイレはこちらでやってくださいとかね
キャンキャンと吠えるなよとかね
いろんなことを だから犬はだから成長しますよ
結構犬っていうのはかなり立派なところいっぱいあります
すごい献身的で謙虚で
だから人間 犬のこと好きなんですよ
他のキツネも飼ったって悪くないでしょうに
あの人の言うことは聞かないんだからね
だから犬には縦の関係はできているんです
すごく素晴らしい性格を持ってるんだから
そこでこの治療にも使ってるでしょ
このお年寄りの方々とかね
もうすごく暗くて落ち込んでいる場合は
まあその犬たちよく知ってますね
自分たちがちゃんとした大事な仕事をしているんだと
だからもうどんな人にも嫌な気持ちしないで
そばに行って もう そばにいてあげる
それで年寄りの方方は犬を触ったり
抱っこしたり で まあ犬にとってみれば不便なところはいっぱいあると思いますけど
もう車椅子で手足は動かないわ
もうちゃんと丁寧に抱っこできないわとか
それは気にしないで ちゃんとこのそういう治療の犬たちはしっかりと仕事はするんです
はるかに人間よりはもうすごい立派だなと思いますよ
だから犬が成長してますよ
生命を助けることとか
何のことなく学んでいる
それは縦の関係で成り立ったものなんです
神々の言葉を聞く 神神にではなくて
神と一体になるなどの話は世間で溢れていますが
生命の法則から見るとほとんどあり得ないんです
そんなのは まあはっきり言えば病気でしょうね
しかし 不可能ということでもありません
よく神の神様がこう頂いたとか
みんな嘘でしたと 今まで
言ったことは 昔話も最近のも
でもね まあこの十年 五年間でね
で 2000年になる前はね
99年  1999 年までひどかったんだから
もう神の言葉を聞く連中は至る所にいて
皆嘘でしたでしょうに
それで現代 この科学時代での神の言葉を聞く連中は完璧な嘘だったら
なんで 2000年前の人々は本物だったと思うんですかね
何か法律 何か理屈はある
お釈迦様ははっきり言っても病気だと
それは バラモン教で しかし
不可能ということじゃないんです
不可能ではないんです
だって お釈迦様は年中もう神々で喋っていたんだから
もうただな 普通の人間と同じく
もう時間があると来て話をして出て行ったりする
当時のお坊さんたちの場合でも
別に何のことなく日中三時でも喋ったりしていたんです
バラモン教でブラフマーと一体になること
ブラフマサハウェーターなんですね
最終目的にした人々がブッダのアドバイスを聞いたところ
ブッダはブラフマーと同じ性格を育てることを勧めたんです
このヒンドゥ教で 当時のブッダの時代のヒンドゥ教で
最終目的はブラフマという神様と一体になることなんですね
お釈迦様が言ったのは
あなた方はね 全然道知らないんだと
方法はダメだと 絶対なりませんよと
そのやり方で言うと 教えてくださいと言うと
いろんなたとえでね 何が一体になるのかというと
似たものが一体になるんだと
水と鉄は一体になりませんよ
水と牛乳だったら何のことなく一緒になっちゃうんです
どこかで似てないと だからそのバラモン人に聞くんです
神様どうですか？嫉妬するんですか？慈しむ人でしょうかと
神様はもう完璧な慈しみだよと
神様は憎しむ人ですか？憐れむ人で憐れむんだよと
あなた方の神様は生命に幸福を与える人でしょうか
どうでしょうかと それで聞いて喜ぶ人であると
気持ちは平等に持っている人でしょうか
あるいはえらい差別主義でしょうかと言ったら
これは平等だよと だったらあなたも慈悲喜捨を育てなさいよと
限りなく それで梵天と一緒になるんだ
事実だと教えたんです
だから上の次元とコンタクトを取りたく
取りたいならば これを持ちたければ自分の人格を上げるしかないんです
で これこういうところに入っています
ディーガニカー長部経典で 13番目の経典提示して
そちらで明確に神と一緒になる方法というのを教えています
これは別に仏教はそれは目的じゃないんです
バラモン人に教えてあげたんです
これマジュムニカーにあの 47番目スッタなんですけど
これは サンジなんとかスッタなんですけど
入れ忘れたんですけどね
サールプット尊者があるサンジャっていうバラモンの友達なんです
で それでまあこいつ その人はね
もういい加減な人で 悪いことばっかりやってるんです
サーリプッタ尊者がもうあんたどうでしょうか
徳でも善行為しているのかと言ったら
そんな暇がないんだと
親の面倒見なくちゃいけないし
子供の面倒見なくちゃいけないし
使用人の面倒見なくちゃいけないし
それからお客の接待しなくちゃいけないし
王様の面倒見なくちゃいけないし
私もご飯食べたり 体のことをしなくちゃいけないのに暇がないんだと
そしたら あ そう ではあなたはね
親の面倒を見るために殺生したり
泥棒したり 盗んだり 嘘言ったり
人を騙したりすると 地獄に落ちたところであなた弁解してくださいと
私は地獄に落とさないでください
私は親の面倒を見るために殺生したんだよ
盗みやったんだよと それで無罪にしてくれるかと
それはないでしょうと
で そうやってもう全部彼の話をね
切ってしまって あれこれと意訳してね
悪いことしたって悪い結果になるんだよと
それで話終わって それから後で
この人は病気になって倒れちゃって死にかけていたんですね
その時もサーリプッタ尊者がいて
まあどうですかね もうもう死んでることはわかりますからね
あんたはどこに生まれ変わりたいんですかね
地獄と畜生だったらどこでしょうかね
と言ったら やっぱり地獄に落ちるよりは畜生の方がいいやと
では餓鬼道だったらどちらにするんでしょうかと言ったら
だったら餓鬼道の方がいいですね
畜生よりも そうでは餓鬼道と人間界ならどこに行きたいのかと
なんかサーリプッタ尊者のことを信じていたんです
このお坊様ならとにかくそちらに入れてくれるそうと
やっぱり餓鬼道 餓鬼道よりは人間の世界はよろしいと
そうだったら 人間よりは四天王の方で生まれたらどうでしょうかね
あ これありがたい話でしょ
四天王よりは夜摩天の方はどうでしょうかと
もっと上なんです 六天もように四天のよりヤマ天の方が上と
で 三十三天はどうでしょうかと
四天のヤマ天に それはまたありがかっちゃうんですね
次にあるのは兜率天で
じゃあ三十三天に生まれるよりは兜率天に生まれたらどうでしょうかと
あ それはもっとありがたいんだと
じゃあ聞きますけど 兜率天よりは上にある
あのえっとえっとえっとえっと
えっとえっと  take 自在天でした
じゃなくて 自在天自在天という名前ですね
とにかく天国の名前だからどうでもいいんですよね
で 生まれたらどうでしょうかと
やっぱりそれ一番ありがたいと
自由自在に喜ぶ世界で
そこでもっと上には take 自在天どうでしょうかと
take 自在天っていうのは自分では何もしない
他の人々はの作っている環境で喜んでいるんです
で それは一番ありがたい
ちょっと待って 天界よりは梵天に生まれたらどうでしょうかと聞いたところで
このバラモン人がびっくりしちゃったんです
自分たちの宗教でずっと言っていることで
誰にも想像つかない話なんです
梵天に生まれるということはできっこはないと思っているんです
仏教とと同じなんです
悟りなんかありっこはないとか
で サーリプッタ梵天というんでしょうかね
梵天だよと どうでしょうかと
梵天はなんか何て言いますかな
旅行会社みたいで いろいろ提案する
こちらどうでしょう こちらどうでしょうかと
梵天だよと 本当に梵天ですかと
もうそうだよと言ったら
この人のサーリプッタ尊者勝手に決めたんですよ
やっぱりこのバラモン人だから
どうせバカだからね 梵天以外のことはね
気にしないでしょうと
興味ないでしょと思って
梵天に行く道を教えたんです
では 道を教えますよ と言って
この慈悲喜捨をその場で実践させて教えてあげてやらせたんです
で 一旦本人がもう慈悲喜捨の気持ちになったところで
もうでは帰りますよと帰ったんですよ
サーリプッタ尊者が立って出ていると聞いて
バラモン 人間死んじゃったんです
死んじゃって 見事に梵天に生まれ変わったんです
約束通り そこでお釈迦様のところにサーリプッタ尊者が来ると
お釈迦様が遠くでサーリプッタ尊者に言って
比丘たちに言うんです
あのサーリプッタが あの自分の友達をね
卑しい梵天に生まれ変わ変わらせて送っているところだと
褒めてなかったんです
悪口言ってるんです いわゆる低いね
卑しいというんですか
このレベル低い梵天に生まれ変わるようにして帰ってるんだと
で まあそれだけのブッダの感想で
わからないんですよ まあお釈迦様ならもう悟り開けるまでやるかもしれませんだけど
サーリプッタ尊者にそういう判断ミス
いくつか 2つぐらいあります
判断ミスかどうか言えませんだけどね
そういうお釈迦様は厳しく言ってるんです
智慧の第一人者ですけど
微妙な間違いあって そこはちゃんと
だから この これは関係ないエピソードで
とにかくこの真面目に聞くには
その経典はダナージャニ経典では出ているんです
で だから上に縦の関係を作りたければ
自分が人格的に成長するということはもう必ず必要なんです
それで最後のところに入ります
心の管理と幸福 すべては自分の意のままで起きているが
納得いかないのはなぜでしょうか
と それで一切自分の意のままで起きてますよ
自分の期待通りに物事は行ってます
でも納得いかないんですね
心っていうのは最大の権力者
心によって管理されて左右されて生きている
それでは生命は皆十分満足して
納得して 幸福に満たして生きているはずでしょう
心の期待通りですからね
しかし 人間 人間人生は不満
不安 苦に満ちているんです
それっておかしいんですよ
一切心が管理して支配してるんだったら
なんで不満でしょうかね
期待 希望は叶った試しはありません
我々の立場から見れば
期待希望なんかはもう叶った試しはないぐらいですよ
本当のところそうじゃないんですよ
期待通りに 希望通りに来てるんです
本当のところは でも不満があるんですね
それは知と矛盾の問題があるんです
知ることと ちょっと事実と矛盾があるんです
心は知るが 事実あるのままの状態を知ろうとしないんです
知るがあるのままに事実を知ろうとしないんですね
自分の都合に合わせて知るのです
ほとんどこの主観は客観的な事実と一致しないんです
勝手に知ってるんであって
ありのままに知ろうとしないんですよ
そこで差が生じるんですよ
たまにでも一致した場合は
物事はうまくいくんです
例えばこの科学的に作っている品物
ちゃんとうまく機能しているでしょうに
それは外との事実に合ってるんだからなんです
我々は知ってはいるんだけど
それは主観で都合によって知るんであって
だから事実とはすごい差があるんです
たまたま合ってる時はうまくいってるんです
希望通りに 自分の体の中の妄想は事実と違うんです
それで我々の希望は全部体の中で妄想してるでしょうに
事実はまるっきり違うんです
うまくいくはずがないんです
生命の知識は天道と言いますね
逆さまやと あるものは無いとするし
ないものはあるとしちゃうし
例えば一切は無常なの
一切というと全ての現象は無常なのに
我々はそうじゃないと思っているんです
魂はないのにあると思っているわけです
とにかく一切人間の知識
知ということが天道ですよ
逆さま それまた別の仏教ではヴィパッサナーという概念の中で説明しています
ヴィパッサナーも四つなんです
それから結果に文句を言うんです
原因に文句を言うのではなく
結果が出たら結果に文句を言うんですね
ですから 人生の起こる出来事に納得いかないんですよ
だから結果に文句を言ったってだったら納得いかないということでしょうに
結果に文句を言うのはバカバカらしいんですよ
原因に文句言わないと
怒り 憎しみ 欲 落ち込み
高慢 見栄 無知などの感情で喜んで進んで知識人のアドバイスを無視して行動しているでしょ
どんな人でも見栄で欲で怒りでも進んで行動していますよ
知識人がそんなことやめなさい
毒ないと言ったっても聞かない
我々はえらい勝手に行動しています
それ全部悪い感情でやってます
それで悪い結果にはなります
当然な当たり前の結果が現れたらそれを嫌がるんです
例えば子供がふざけて遊びばっかししやがっちゃって
それで学校の成績が悪いんだと落ち込んだりする
結果に文句を言ったって意味がないでしょうに
それで死ぬまで納得いかない人生になるんです
結果に文句言ってはならない
今更文句を言っても後の祭りです
これ正しいかどうかわかりませんだけど
今はどうにもならないんです
結果には 結果に文句を言っても
だから喧嘩結果に文句を言う性格がある限り
人生は不満で苦しみで
もう不安でもうたまらないんですよ
嫌で 良い結果を期待するなら
えーと 何かの良いとする結果を期待するなら
理性ある人はやみくみに行動するのではなく
原因に注意するんですよ
原因は大事なんです どのような原因が
それば結果は期待通りになるのかと注意するんです
原因をそろったことは自分の意思で実行するもので
そろうことはね 結果は自然に現れる
原因を揃えることは自分の責任なんですよ
原因そろったら自然に結果が出てくる
結果に文句を言ったっても意味がないんです
例えば 窓ガラスを目掛けて石を投げて
石を投げて顔を隠しちゃっても
もうどうにもならんですよ
ガラスは割れちゃうんです
ガラス割って欲しくなかったら
最初からもうあの原因作らなかったらよかったんです
だから原因の時点で気をつけないんだから
みんな失敗するんです
我々に管理できるのは
心で管理できるのは原因のところです
結果のところじゃないんです
結果はもう必ず来る